foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to our presentation we
hope you've had a great conference so
far
so there's always thing that goes like
this all is well that starts with a good
story
I made that up do not satisfy saying
however my colleague and I thought to
bring great style something the reason
it should ask our experience and our
talk
so here's a quote from one of our
favorite books outside by Justin
Wonderland and goes like this for you
see some of the way things have happened
clearly that Ali said got to think that
very few things indeed were really
impossible
so what we talking about this I was to
put it into a little bit of context this
account moment it was the following clip
B2 and G2
as you can see these are voice control
robotic arm which is starting to go
certain locations on a chess board and
do some tasks so what if we told you the
majority of this was done in r
my name is Eric panchal and I'm Jim but
my lovely colleague Ian mushiri and
today we're talking about a touch of Art
and Robotics
so you may be wondering whoa make two
guys do a project in r in particular
politics so here's the story one of the
reasons that uh led us into this
adventure was hardly become so a while
ago when Ian and I were getting started
in R and doing some of our electoral
electronics engineer projects which
taught him asking for the art can
program some of these devices we're
dealing with and also a good
recommendation for some machine learning
books it's hardly been hardly was really
honest with us and he told us that that
time we don't know anything about uh
Raspberry Pi or arctin or some of these
devices but it gave us a good starting
point uh in machine learning so thanks
thanks for that hardly and with this
response you know got us thinking so
well like if honey doesn't know about
this no we figured it out and shared it
with the art community then that would
be a really uh great impact to the
community in general
so this is one of the reasons so the
second reason was that Ian and I were
involved in California data science club
in our former University of Technology
in Kenya and we get and we kept on
getting these questions so we see a lot
of ingenious things happening with R in
other domains such as sports or medicine
or Pharma what can us do in electrical
electronics engineering the two reasons
that really made us think and you know
made us uh try out our in what we love
doing and that is uh electronics and
Robotics and uh all that stuff so this
is where the story began anyhow back to
Art and Robotics so in this talk we'll
be presenting a series of steps in which
we used R to achieve motion of the
robotic comedy so uh and uh hopefully uh
at the end of it all you'll see how how
art played a pivotal role in the success
of this project so Ian to a simple
vertical um what do I actually need
yeah to move a simple robotic arm the
first thing that you need to do is
actually set up your robotic arm which
basically means setting up the hardware
that you're going to be using and the
beauty about this is that the pieces
already come you know are pre-cut all
you have to do is actually remove the
pieces and actually assemble them
together and once you do this uh you can
it only takes about 30 minutes to an
hour and with the right enthusiasm I can
actually do this and you're already done
with the first step which is actually
setting up the manipulator so after
you're done with the self tab after
you're done with the hardware uh you
proceed to ask the the mo the next
logical question becomes what are the
manipulator inputs and just as a
disclaimer in the course of this talk I
will be using the term manipulator and
robotic arm to mean one and the same
thing so I don't get lost in that so you
realize from the video that Eric just
shown us that our manipulator used voice
as an input so how did we achieve this
in art so the first thing that you do
actually record The Voice using audio
package in R whereby we recorded the
command P2 and G2 once you have our
voice input we transcribed this using
Azure Azure cognitive services and
transcribed the voice input into text
using HDR package and Json light package
I'm sure some of you are familiar with
that
after doing that the transcription and
getting the output
we proceeded next to do some assertions
to ensure that indeed the formats that
result that we got from Azure is
actually correct because you realize in
some cases there's some errors and after
doing this we extracted the characters
from the text whereby B2 was the initial
position and it was the final position
so to make the API call to Azan we use
the sample code shown in the slide
whereby all you needed to do is actually
Define our subscription key which you
actually got from Azure once we set up
our cognitive services on the platform
Define the context type which was audio
file the flavor of English that you're
using which was us English uploaders are
recorded audio got the transcript the
transcribe data using a post request to
the API and then from this we actually
pulled the initial position and the
final position in text format so just to
recap what's the state of data at this
point so at this point we had our voice
input B2 and G2 run it through Azure and
then we got a string equivalent a string
which is B2 and G2 representing a
specific chessboard just just chest box
actually which is B2 and G2 which is the
final position so after after deriving
the string the next bit becomes you know
defining the workspace whereby the
manipulator will be working on and to
answer this we ask ourselves the
question where is the manipulator
actually going and I believe Eric are
you going to tell us where where was the
manipulator going
to answer your question and what we need
to do is to assign a special coordinate
to the to the chessboard location that
we just uh obtained from the
transcription so how did we approach
this so we started first started by
creating a virtual board in art using
tgplot uh probably a lot of you
obviously to create some elegant
Graphics in R once we did this we
extracted the centroid pixel location
and then the next point was uh
translating the pixel location to actual
real world coordinates in centimeters so
and to do this we use the skills package
in R so why did we have what did you use
this approach so we figured out that
different boats come in different
flavors and dimensions so we needed a
virtual ball that is static and then
depending on the dimensions of the
chessboard one can then you know
translate the pixel location to actual
real world location depending on the uh
on the dimensions of his or her board so
at this point uh we can combine
everything and put it in a good old
table so we have the position of
um of of the square box in the on the
chessboard and most importantly the X
and Y coordinates are in centimeters of
what that would represent a location of
a chest piece on a chessboard so let's
wrap this up so we started with uh with
with speech and then we got a
transcription and then for each start
and end point we have we now have x and
y coordinate X Y and Z coordinator to
present the position of our chest piece
on chessboard so for instance B2 can be
represented by 6 centimeter on the X 15
centimeter and the Y and 3.5 on the Z so
3.5 is just at the height of the chest
piece that will be moving around on the
chessboard so the next logical question
now becomes how with the manipulator get
there
yeah so to answer this question I just
take a moment and just observe the video
that's playing and you realize from the
video that uh that these three blue
things that have some cables connected
to them those are actually Motors and
they are responsible for the manipulator
motion and in this case we had three
motors which were controlling motion and
yeah and you realize with the motor the
motion of a motor is actually rotational
in nature and from Eric's points we now
have our coordinates in terms of X Y and
Z so we have to find a way of linking
the XYZ and the motor angles at
converting XYZ coordinates into the
equivalent motor angles and to do this
we use a branch of math called inverse
kinematics I know it's a mouthful but
just bear with us for a second yeah
so at the moment let's treat inverse
kinematics as a black box so what
inverse kinematics does uh does in a
nutshell is it takes XYZ inputs converts
them into the equivalent angles
therefore we have our XYZ coordinates
which are actually converted into motor
angles that can now move the manipulator
and just to give you a feel of what
inverse kinematics is all about I give
you some fair warning there's some other
head so just uh hold on tight and just
bear with us and uh yeah so
to do inverse kinematics it's actually
based on trigonometry functions which
are you know the other things that most
of us learned in elementary and just
need to brush up a little bit on yeah
and the beauty about this is that most
robotic arms once you buy the kit uh it
comes with the instructions to inverse
kinematics most probably people that
their people their ripples out there
whereby people have already done the
inverse kinematics so you don't really
have to know you know the Deep stuff
about these things so you just need a
high level overview just use the code
that is being used by other people yeah
and uh in case it's not there in case
it's not provided you can actually come
up with your own and this is a sample of
what we actually did and as you can see
you use the basic you know uh tangent uh
sign and cosine functions that you know
uh we learned in elementary so all you
need to do is actually uh is actually
you know brush upon those skills and
then yeah we'll probably give a a more
detailed approach as to how we came up
with this okay
yeah so just to recap what's the state
of data at this point so at this point
we got our audio file which was the
input we transcribed it and got the
string B2 and G2 if we try which we
actually transpose the B2 and G2 into
the real world XYZ coordinates that
represented you know uh chess chess
piece locations of the chessboard and
using inverse kinematics web on how to
translate the XYZ into the equivalent
motor angles and you realize that since
we have three motors the way we identify
which which is which model is actually
by using the string so a letter A
corresponded to the first motor B to the
second motor letter C to the rad motor
so 112 element 112 degrees 2 is water a
126 B meant 126 decreased motor B 107
cement 107 C 107 degrees to motor motor
C driver
and finally go to the fun part which is
actually moving the robotic arm so Eric
how did you move the manipulator to the
desired positions so let's answer in
this question at this point we have
everything that we need to move the
chest pieces on the chessboard so you
know you know the location of the chest
please and you know the angles required
to move the monitorial to that position
so we now need to find a way of linking
R and the manipulator and how to do this
so this is architecture that we used
where I install the heavy lifting and
finally sending a string of data that
Ian just described and at the middle we
have an electric device known as a
microcontroller and a microcontroller
you can think of it as an electrical
device or you can connect multiple
peripherals such as Motors or LEDs or
speakers or sensors then Define some uh
some instructions on how to send
electrical signals to
um
to manipulate the peripherals that is
connected to it in our case the search
Motors won't sound when the motors to
rotate to some given angles so that was
the work of the microcontroller which in
our cases after you know just receive a
string of data and then send a signal to
each respective motor then the motor
should rotate and bring the manipulator
to the desired con to the desired
position so once we have this figure out
the next
um you know logical thing was now to ask
ourselves how do we send data uh from R
to the microcontroller and this point is
when we realize that most
microcontrollers are that can can be
programmed via a Serial interface so a
Serial interface is our communication
interface in which data can be sent and
received sequentially so with with this
we just had we just had to figure out
how to set up a Serial interface in R
um and then a microcontroller can read
that serial interface and you know send
uh send the electro signal to move our
uh to move our Motors and bring the
manipulator to the desired position so
how do you set up a Serial interface in
R you know surprisingly enough there's
already a packet that uh that helps us
that do this so the package known as
packet zero so with Siri just requires
the zero packet just requires some few
parameters to set up the serial
interface and some of these parameters
are in power parameters uh important
arguments rather is uh the bot the bot
number so this is the USB port which you
connect the um the micro controller to
to your PC
the next thing the next argument is the
uh the bound rate so this is the rate at
which you send and receive data which
was 9 600 bits per second so you want a
speed that is just right not too fast
not too slow and the next parameters are
are there by default and they and they
just help in structuring how data is
sent to the zero interface for instance
do you want a new line appended uh uh at
each at each instance of the data yes
what what what what what uh what
character you want to append after each
new line Uh current return so this just
describes how to how to send how to
structure data that is sent to the
serial interface and after you've done
how to set up the serial interface you
now write data to it and to write data
to it we just um you know combined the
the strings of angles into a vector then
we use password to write each uh each
element of the vector to the to the
serial to the serial connection so
um once the data is on a serial
connection now the uh it's time for the
microcontroller to read that data into
its thing so these are the instructions
that uh we put on the microcontroller
acquired by it checks
um whether data is available on the
serial uh reads reads data from the
serial passes integers to extract the
numeric part of the string and then
depending on the case say a b or c it
writes that uh that value or you know
that that integer to
um to the respective mode associated
with with
um with with a string for instance if it
says a it knows I'm sending an angle to
motor a b sends an angle to water B and
at this point we have achieved
um uh the basis of our whole project you
know we started from transcribing
transcribing data uh all the way to
knowing the angles to which to move the
our robotic arm and finally moving our
robotic arm using the help of a
microcontroller so with this you can set
up some I would say some some more
complex tasks uh such as achieving a
capture move in uh using online using
our manipulator like we're going to see
in the following clip
G3 and B2 captcha
thank you
perfect so this basically using all that
information that we have uh you know
that the clue described and just adding
some layers of complexity to it and at
this point we hope you have successfully
showed you some touch of Art in robotics
so
um everything has some pros and cons
right here
yeah definitely everything has its own
pros and cons and uh in the course of
this project we realized that there are
some key areas that we wanted to
highlight that are really excelled and
one of the Curious that we saw that rxel
does when it came to data manipulation
it was easier to do data manipulation
with r because I realized that R is
actually optimized for such tasks and
also we realized in the course of the
projects that a big chunk of Robotics is
actually at least a problem and it can
also easily be solved in Earth therefore
it became quite easy using R and also R
is actually less computationally
expensive as compared to what you used
before which was a much lab it's a
software that actually is used by guys
in our field specifically the guys doing
research and the reason was really say
this is because you realize with Matlab
once you boot it up it loads all the
packages that that come with Matlab but
you realize with r you only load the
packages that you need therefore it
becomes a bit light on the PC and it
becomes easier to use and also RS open
source therefore meaning anybody can
actually reproduce what you did once uh
once they have like access to uh there
they are and actually it becomes easier
to actually do this without uh having so
much of resources so the issues the main
issues that we Face using uh when using
are was that the serial communication
which Eric just highlighted was a bit
slower yeah and we we thought such maybe
this could be an issue with the package
and it's something that we are willing
to look at in future and maybe offer
some suggestions and also the audio
package that you use to record audio was
a bit it wasn't up to date because each
and every time after recording an audio
an audio an audio objects driver we had
to restart ads so that you can actually
record Another audio objects meaning you
can't do two consecutive inputs without
fast necessarily having to restart which
was a bit annoying and you know it is a
bit hectic so
what's next because you know like what
what's next which is our next adventure
So currently we plan on adding and
contributing our packages specifically
packages here towards the engineering
field because we believe that given our
background is something that can
actually you know uh add to the
community and actually build the
community and also speaking about
communities we also want to build our
company communities specifically in
engineering such as what you have in you
know medicine are in Pharma you want to
also to have a community of art that of
our results that are actually in the
engineering field and also because the
adventurous we hope that you will
explore other unexpected us over and
once we are able to get something we'll
share with with everyone yeah and uh
Eric I don't know if there's anything
else that I left house
not much here everything was really well
said and uh thanks a lot for that so
hoping that we get to the next uh
Adventure soon so by anyhow we really
wanted to wrap everything up but just uh
noting that uh a lot of the majority did
we did using packages that are already
in the arc system we thought but when we
were starting this actually we had to
reinvent some tools but uh there was no
need for that everything used us
everything that has already been built
and uh we just had to modify it to our
needs so we hope uh we really present a
good case of an unexpected using R and
mostly we hope that you've inspired one
or two to try out uh you know are in
their domain or you know art or uh in
some fun activities they have you know
just using our everyone anywhere so
anyhow time to wrap up
um so we'd hope to wrap up with you know
let's say a quote from Alison why
Wonderland like we did from at the
beginning but we have we did not find
one that's really befitting to our story
so we made one up so if this ever still
returnable Eric and Ian we hope it goes
like this you know for you see similar
out of the way things had happened
lately that Eric and yeah began to think
that very few things indeed were really
impossible and an emphasis with the art
in impossible
so thank you so much for listening to us
uh please do have a good conference
ahead and take care of yourselves so
talk soon and bye
my
[Music]